a Golgi apparatus the most amazing thing
about this is Alex true love is going to
have sex next week huh hot sweaty
intercourse of a sexual kind
oh my name is Alex Chula yes that's my
real name I have a 4.0 GPA I'm student
body president and I have a great
girlfriend you're coming with us to this
party and you're gonna let your little
constipated hair down and enjoy yourself
one join the cool kids
I think we're here to corrupt you Alex
[Music]
so I have a girlfriend I know she's
adorable Cheers
there's this guy I'm pretty sure has a
crush on me and I guess I'm not repulsed
by the idea look it's a confusing time
man everywhere you look someone is
omnisexual or transitioning how did you
know you were gay how do you know you're
straight
what's going on I'm trying to do virgin
eyes you for the past eight months you
won't let me
it's like Mad Max out here you guys
doing guys girls doing girls girls
turning into guys and doing girls that
used to do girls in guys ah
I'm over at though his whole thing sex
love I'm out see someone these explain
modern high school boys to me
what are you so scared of
love is strange
danger
you
[Music]
you